this is a production of Cornell
University so the first thing I want to
do is to thank all of you for coming
this afternoon it's a pleasure to to be
here and in the next I would say a
little over than half an hour 40 minutes
I'd like to talk a little bit about
micro Z and I'm pretty sure most of you
are familiar with mycorrhizae and I see
some familiar faces here who work with
mycorrhizae so I'd like to approach this
area from commercial standpoint a little
bit so you would have an idea of you
know at my kreizel applications how we
handle this topic and what kind of
research we do here so just as an
introduction my cry self and I formed
symbiosis with plants and most of the
plants have this ability to form
symbiosis over 90% of the land plants
reported to form symbiosis and they live
in the soil and they interact with the
roots so they don't go to the leaves and
any other part of the plan my crazy
provides a better absorption of
nutrients and increase the water uptake
to the plant and this is the benefit so
where the plant from the mycorrhizae
however this is not free so the fungus
requires from the plans to provide
carbon in return so this is some kind of
a holistic relationship a symbiosis
between the plant and the fungus where
both of both of the participants have
benefits they cannot function without
living plants and this is very important
from commercial standpoint when when you
apply like microcell inoculum and
there's no plant in the soil you don't
really see the benefits of mycorrhizae
because there's no plant to interact
with the fungus no way the plants
control this symbiosis so when the
plants are under stressful conditions by
drought stress or nutrient stress they
produce
exudates that triggers microspores to
germinate so this is how you know the
symbiosis starts to form they increase
the nutrient and the water absorption
Twitter plants by increasing the
absorption so and this is not just
increasing the root biomass biomass but
also for a mycelium around the root zone
that actually expands or extends this
absorption area and I'm gonna have a
couple of slides about this you know
what the details are but this aspects so
they increase the tolerance to various
stressors like drought stress so it's
stress in every stress heavy metal
toxicity and I'm gonna talk a little bit
about this as well and there are
different types of micro I see that
exist and so the most important ones are
endo mycorrhizae or vascular micro I see
they got their name after their
relationship structural relationship
with the plant so actually they
penetrate inside the cortical cells of
the plant roots that's why they are
called endo mycorrhizae because they go
inside the cells they are called Airbus
Keeler my crazy as well and most of the
agricultural horticultural plants belong
to this category or foreign symbiosis
with this type of micro I see there's
another type of mycorrhizae called ecto
mycorrhizae that actually do not
penetrate inside a cortical cells they
form a mental around the roots and they
form the symbiosis or they or their
hyphy in the intracellular spaces of the
roots and they are acting micro I see
they they live in symbiosis with
hardwoods forests trees vines spruces
for example there's a very specific kind
actually a subtype of actor microns II
accidental mycorrhizae
they represent only a very tiny portion
of the plans and the symbiosis or
kids have a specific type of my crazy
they're called orchid mycorrhizae so
they do not form symbiosis with actor
Mike rising for example ericaceous
plants like blueberries azalea or
rhododendron they form symbiosis with
ericaceous mycorrhizae that's a very
specific type of micro Z and there are
very great tiny portions like only one
genus or one blend species that corn
symbiosis with Buddhist plants or ma non
troppo the ghost plant they represent
only a very tiny portion so these are
just to mention but but the main types
are under my crazy and XO my crazy and
I'm gonna talk a little bit about these
today focusing on endo my crisis so when
we talk about endo mycorrhizae we know
that they formed symbiosis with a large
number of plants over 80% of the plants
form symbiosis with them and as I
mentioned they colonize the roots inside
there what color eyes the plants inside
the roots and so it's not that easy to
recognize just by looking at the plants
if the plant is colonized or not so what
we have to do is we have to collect the
roots clear them stain them and evaluate
them under the microscope and so this is
just an example how a prepared root
sample looks like so when we when we
clear the roots and and stain them this
is what we see that there's practically
nothing really nothing interesting in
the roots however when we look at a root
with mycorrhizae but you can see that to
see different structures inside the
roots these are spores and vesicles that
are storage organs for the mycorrhizae
and also mycelium inside the roots and
Arbus Chios so these are tiny like tree
like structure
that are actually responsible for the
exchange of nutrients between the fungus
and the flam's
and yeah basically this is how we
evaluate different plants to detect the
presence of my cries there's another
kind of mycorrhizae ecto mycorrhizae
that form symbiosis with less than 10%
of plant species and the major host
bands are coniferous or D seduce trees
Cruz spruces pine trees that form
symbiosis and these are actually
mushrooms that form fruiting bodies in
the forest so when you walk in the
forest and you see different trees you
see that ecto mycorrhizae or or
mushrooms form on the surface of the
ground and they are every time it's
connected interconnected with with the
plants around them so that's a very
interesting phenomenon and when we
compare the ecto mycorrhizae and endo
mycorrhizae in terms of appearance you
can actually see that the difference in
root morphology because the roots
normally look a bit different so this is
a very nice example the fly agaric for
ecto mycorrhizae and and then you look
at the roots
these are colonized by Ekta mycorrhizae
and usually this notorious in this case
and this is non colonized so it actually
really visible in in case of ecto Micra
see how larger the root could be or how
their morphology could change just by
the colonization of this fungus and this
really helps in increasing the
absorption area of the roots and taking
up more nutrients and water from the
soil
when you look at take a look at the
roots and this is particularly true for
endo mycorrhizae so these are their
roots and and these are the fungal
mycelium or or or hike the around the
roots and some spores
what you can see as well so the
mycorrhizae form this symbiosis and they
live inside the roots and also outside
the roots they form some species can
form spores outside the roots and some
species inside the roots as most of them
actually do both so when we talk about
mycorrhizae from commercial standpoint
growers always ask why why by plants
leave my crazy so they have roots and
couldn't just they take up nutrients and
water efficiently without mycorrhizae
and so we try to explain the difference
the structural and functional benefits
what mycorrhizae can provide when we
compare the root hair and the micro
fungal hyphae so when we look at the
roots this is a plant root here and this
is the root hair that actually is
responsible for taking up most of the
nutrients and the water and the maximum
length of the root hair is only a few
millimetres so that's that's a very tiny
area or so or soil volume that they can
explore to take up the nutrients and the
water and the good ion absorption occurs
only at the root tips so the absorption
is only at the root tips so that's a
very tiny area for nutrient and water
update and another important thing that
we have to consider is that the nutrient
uptake is normally from the available or
for easily soluble pool of the soil and
of the soil nutrients and I'm gonna talk
a little bit about it in a minute and
of this tiny absorption area at the root
tips the nutrient inflow into the roots
is normally slower much slower than my
cries oh hi see cuz when we when we look
at the micro eyes or high feet or that
network of microns on - the roots we see
a huge difference from from plant roots
because what you can see here is this is
a root a feeder root that is responsible
for for nutrient uptake and this network
of mycelium rounded or mycorrhizae and
what you have to see here is that
maximum length could be up to two feet
so basically what happens is they can
extend this depletion zone we call the
depletion zone where the nutrients and
the water uptake occurs by two feet
which is which could be extremely
important under drought conditions the
nutrient and the water absorption occurs
along the entire length of the hyphy so
it's not just the tips but the entire
length to take up nutrients and water so
that's a it's a huge increase in
absorption area mineral nutrient uptake
from the soluble and insoluble fou so I
just have to mention that they produce
enzymes like phosphatases that helps
solubilizing phosphate and easier to
take up for the plants and also they
take up nutrients and transport it to
the plant as well and because of this
increased absorption area or absorptive
area the nutrient inflow into the high
feet and from the high key to the plan
it's much faster much quicker compared
to the root of pig so this is why and
this is how my crazy increases the
nutrients and the water uptake of the
plant
and under field conditions when we when
we look at you know mycorrhizae you know
and how it works and and this is what I
was just talking about that there's a
root zone where you know major if it's
soil volume where the major it a of the
roots are located on and take up the
nutrients and the water and what my
crazy does it extends is soil volume and
this is how they can provide benefits
and this is very important for those
nutrients that are relatively that have
a relatively low mobility like
phosphorus primarily and some of the
micronutrients because they cannot just
move easily into that depletion zone so
that's that's very important and yes
this is very helpful for the plant and
then again this is for field conditions
so when there's a possibility for the
roots or the mycorrhizae to explore a
larger soil however there are certain
conditions when and there's just no it's
not an option to explore a larger soil
volume because there's just no more soil
and this is particularly true for
spotting conditions when and the plants
are grown in a pot and and they form
these these roots and you know these are
ruined by root bound situations so my
crazy steel provides the benefits even
though there's there's no larger soy
poem to explore so they produce enzymes
that convert nutrients into bioavailable
form so I just mentioned the
phosphatases
and they also trigger the production of
solubilizing enzymes by the plant roots
so they increase this activity through
the plant and they also work together
with other soil microorganisms and very
insoluble minerals into soluble forms so
these are called micro as our helper
bacteria for example that live together
in symbiosis with the mycorrhizae and
helped solubilizing non-soluble
nutrients and due to these mechanisms
they reduced nutrient leaching out of
the parts and there's an excellent study
that actually looked at the effect of
micro appliqu micro SD micro fungal
application on in potting soil
conditions when they grew ornamental
plants and they looked at nitrogen or
nitrate and order phosphate leaching out
of the plants and this is a bit sly or
this is a busy slide with three graphs
what what I just want to point out here
that these are these graphs show
different fertilizer levels so Osmocote
is a fertilizer
it's a slow-release fertilizer and then
half rate and full rate of fertilisers
so what you can see here is that the
white diamonds on the top in all graphs
show that when my crazy was not applied
let's say untreated control and black
diamonds with black squares show the my
crazy application so you can compare the
amount of nitrate leached out of the
pots so this shows that Mike just by the
application of my cries of fungus and I
reduced the leaching or practically the
leaching of nitrogen where or or the
loss of nitrogen in these conditions so
this is very important that that
mycorrhizae helps a better absorption of
the nutrients to the plants and the
plants can utilize these and and it's a
similar trend with art of order
phosphate so this is a phosphorus source
same thing without mycorrhizae the
phosphorus the amount of phosphorus that
leached out of the pot was I would say
about twice as much as with mycorrhizae
so this is this is something that is
very important and not just in poor
conditions but also
sites we're quite leaching of nutrients
into the soil or the or the waters is a
problem so we talked a little bit about
plants that form symbiosis with
mycorrhizae but there are some plants
that do not form this symbiosis they
just don't have the ability and prime
examples are the brassy KCA family plans
like cabbage broccoli kale cauliflower
mustard so these are these are very good
examples they just don't do not form
this symbiosis and there are different
hypotheses why they do not form this
symbiosis the most probable reason is
that they lost through the evolution
their ability to form this symbiosis
beats also a good example spinach as
well from Horniman toast carnation is
also a good example for the plants that
do not form this simplest type of
seniors and agreed some weeds as well so
you can find examples from every areas
of the plant and but these are the most
important ones and when we when we try
to explain you know why my Kreisler mike
rizzo inoculum and mike rizzo
inoculation is important and how we do
it in in in commercial situations we
normally talk about inoculant technology
and i summarized the basics here on this
slide so when we talk about inoculation
what we do is we provide a direct
contact of the roots with the micro eyes
of fungal inoculum we call it proper
gills because these are structures that
could be used to propagate or reenact
you late the plants with my crazy so
these are spores and colonized root
fragments that we normally
referred to in commercial practice and
I'm gonna have a slide on this so it's
very important to have a close or direct
contact of the inoculum with the roots
because the root exudates trigger and
the mike rizzo spores to germinate my
cries of colonization lasts in most
cases for the life of the plants
so in perennial crops this means that
you have to inoculate only once in their
life and this inoculation could take
place at any time the best you know when
the there's active root growth but with
annual plants you have to renovate the
plants we're not reading actually just
do the inoculation every time when you
see it or when there's a new crop coming
up the most economic benefits and best
physiological responses can be achieved
by early application so what do you what
do I mean by death it means that you
know the earlier you apply the
mycorrhizae the most benefits you're
gonna get out because there's gonna be a
longer period of time for the my crazy
to provide the benefits and also in in
in commercial conditions what happens is
we have a recommended rate like X number
of profit use to apply for plant and
when the plants are smaller you have a
smaller root zone so you can get away
with smaller amounts of microcell
inoculum to get the same colonization or
the same inoculum benefits so that's
it's not just cheaper but its measured
better from from physiological
standpoint as well we normally say that
it requires one month three forty weeks
for the symbiosis to establish well
established on the roots and two months
seven or eight weeks to see the benefits
from inoculations so when when we are
talking about these timeframes we have
to consider you know from commercial
standpoint that when we try to apply
mycorrhizae in a crop that that is only
like a very short cycle
like three or four weeks we might not be
able to see the benefits because there's
just not enough time for the micro Z to
provide this extra benefit to the plant
and the good thing is you cannot
overdose Big Mike Rice or fungi because
they just gonna sit in the soil and and
even bye-bye some animals in the soil
but you know if the plants don't need
this symbiosis
they just won't form the seniors they
just won't germinate in the soil there
are four main benefits that that we
normally mention when we talk about mike
rizzo inoculant and one is increased
root growth so they extend the
absorption area you know by this
formation of mycelium but also at the
same time they help in increasing the
root biomass and this is particularly
important in those crops where the where
the root is the yield so for example in
potato onion and carrots we see great
benefits of using my crazy to increase
the root biomass increased nutrient and
water uptake so this is through day
through the increased absorption area
and also increasing the bioavailability
of nutrients and allowing for reduced
irrigation and better fertilizer
efficiency so there are several papers
out there that shows the benefits of you
know applying mycorrhizae with reduced
rates of fertilizers but as a company we
are not really allowed to say that you
can reduce the fertilizer because you
know if you promote let's say a micro
inoculant other companies we're not
getting any benefits by you know selling
fertilizer products so we have to be
very careful how we word you know these
claims but what we can say is that the
increase
or improve the nutrient absorption
efficiency of the planet increased
stress tolerance under drought heat and
toxic levels of minerals and so it's
very it's a very interesting phenomenon
what how mycorrhizae can help in in
alleviating toxic levels of minerals
because what happens is the mic rise of
fungi take up the nutrients the the
toxic nutrients from the soil but they
just don't transport it to the plant so
this is how they actually protect the
plants because what happens is if the
plant senses that you know there is no
benefit of this symbiosis or this
relationship then they just try to shut
down this again is amore this symbiosis
so that's why the the fungus won't
really transport these toxic levels of
minerals to the plants otherwise the
plant would shut down the symbiosis and
reduce the transplant shop so
transplanting is the most stressful
condition or or face in the you know in
a in a plant's life and the application
of my crazy really helps and and and
under these stressful conditions but as
I mentioned here best if inoculate is
there before transplanting because so
remember it takes like three four weeks
for the symbiosis to form and we apply
the mycorrhizae had a seeding stage so
by the time the transplanting happens
the mycorrhizae is there and can provide
the benefits so that's that's an
important there are other documented
benefits that I I just want to briefly
mention here is increased tolerance to
pests and pathogens so here's a
resistance called systemic resistance
called
micro rise induced resistance there are
several
occasions out there that shows that for
example chewing insects are one of their
targets so when mycorrhizae colonizes
the plans the plans become more
resistant to these insects for example
but these are this is not something that
you can find on a product label for the
micro eyes of products because this is
not well this requires this would
require registration as a pesticide
product which micro IC is not and there
are also more effective more efficient
solutions out there like different
pesticides or insecticides that can take
care of the problem we just mentioned
here that this is something that you can
consider as a positive that's a side
benefit but these are not really so
mycorrhizae micro riser is not really
applied to to solve these problems or to
control insects for example another very
important aspect that seed production
and offspring fertility it's been
noticed that when there's a plant that
is colonized by mycorrhizae and is
producing seeds the seeds from these
mother plants are gonna have a better
fertility and a better germination rate
compared to those that came from mother
plants that were not colonized by my
cries so this has something to do with
the increased nutrient and phosphorus
content of the seeds and this is just
something that is that is very
interesting to dimension also increase
secondary metabolite production in some
plants they positively affect active
ingredient production of medicine or
plants there are several studies showing
that terpenes panels and alkaloids are
increased by after the application of
micro I see
and last but not least increased soil
quality so the production of aluminum
this is a compound that increase the
aggregation of soil particles so this is
very important to to maintain and
improve the soil health by my cries so
why is my cry so inoculation beneficial
and normally under certain under natural
conditions my crazy is always in the
soil there's just a wide range of
species there and they provide benefits
but there are growing conditions that
are harmful to mycorrhizae so for
example fumigation over fertilization
with nitrogen or phosphorus are
especially detrimental to my cries and
you know like tillage following and
stressful environments particularly
roadsides when they put a lot of salt
out you know around the roads in the
winter just to melt the ice that is very
harmful to mycorrhizae and certainly
artificial growing media they just by
nature don't contain any my crazy and
they can they can be my crazy can be
applied under these conditions and so
once they deplete it in the soy just
takes time for the natural population to
build up again and that's why it's
important to to apply my crazy and these
are just a few photos that to illustrate
where my crazy could be beneficial so in
fumigated soils fumigation cures most of
the soil microorganisms over
fertilization is not positive
particularly nitrogen phosphorus for
mycorrhizae and bare-root trees or
transplants are particularly good
subjects for the use of of mycorrhizae
and artificial growing media it's
something where there's micro Z
naturally it's not there
specificity of mycorrhizae so there's a
great deal of variability and let me
know that one species of my crazy can
form the symbiosis with multiple species
of plants and at the same time one plant
roots could form symbiosis with
different species of my crazy so there's
there's just a great deal of variability
but there are different species that are
responsible for different functional
benefits so one species is better for
phosphorus update however other species
of my crazy is better to increase heavy
metal toxicity or to increase the
tolerance to heavy metal toxicity so
there are differences in terms of
species and fungal species change with
plant phenology and plant physiology so
the the composition or the chemical
composition of the root exudates change
over time and even within the season and
also the environment and conditions
change so that the community composition
changes during the season I'm gonna have
a slide about it so that's why the
diversity of mike rizzo inoculants or
microbial inoculants is important to
provide a range of species and so under
different conditions different species
can provide different benefits and this
is just a quick review of one of the
products actually that mike rizzo
application sells it's my co-pilot
contains four different species where we
compiled a or reviewed the literature
and you know 600 papers and we just
collected or listed those that that you
know what species is responsible for
what functional benefits and you can see
that you know different different
species provide different benefits and
for example in in case of Glomus ma CA
in nutrient optic enzyme activity
increase increases access my
to nutrient uptake there's 11 papers
showing the benefits for Glomus masky
some interactions and and and well
communicate them so that's just
important and an interesting to see the
different species provide different
functional benefits and this is just one
slide from one graph from a paper where
they evaluated two natural habitats of
natural habitats of two species so you
can see two bars here and the community
composition over time from July the
following in June and what you can see
here is the different colors show
different genotype for different speed
we can call it different species of my
crazy and and you can see that the color
the colors change within the season so
that's important that there is a change
in diversity of micro so species with
the plant so they you know in the winter
and in the summer there are a different
composition of this like size of
community and this is just one photo
where there's a comparison with a single
species and and the multiple species you
can see that difference in in growth and
this is a grass in case of the grass
inoculum in micro Sol products so we
call them proper use and there are two
main types of propagules colonize root
fragments that contain spores and and
and high tea and other micro structures
and they normally faster in establishing
the relationship to colonize that the
plant roots and also fungal spores so
spores are not only in a dormant stage
and germinate a little bit slower than
than these root fragments so these are
the two main types of propagules in
commercial products
and last but not least a couple slides
on the ways of application how my cries
my cries aw inoculum could be applied so
in in horticulture they could be applied
by just spreading ores in the in the
planting hole so this is a very
efficient way of inoculating the plants
because it provides a direct contact
with the roots so when the plants are
planted in this hole here gonna be in
direct contact with the roots and that's
very important it could be incorporated
in the growing media before or at
planting and mostly granular or powder
product should come into account but the
most important thing is that that you
have to provide a very good blending or
mixing with with the growth medium
because what happens is these tiny cells
where where the plants or the seeds are
gonna be seated they are gonna contain
only two or three propagules on average
so that's really really hard to achieve
under commercial conditions to have a
very very uniform glancing through
dipping this is particularly with with
perennial crops like grapes or apple
trees for example before planting so
growers can just mix up a bucket of
water with some micro inoculum and dip
it in in this plants into this solution
and this is how they provide the direct
contact before planting and the only
thing that you have to be aware is that
the the proper you stance tends to
settle in the bottom of the bucket so
you just have to shake it or we're
mixing with the water the same thing
could be done by a backpack sprayer just
spraying directly on the under root
Micra inoculum could be applied through
irrigation could be overhead or or drip
irrigation depends on the crop and the
best is is to water before before
application to wet the soil profile and
the Micra is a just please micros or
proper use are normally pretty small
less than 300 sometimes 200 microns so
they easily travel through the soil the
wet soil profile so they can get into
that into the root zone and see
treatment some some products already
contain my crazy on their seed coat so
right after germination in the soil the
micros is there the microns of fungus is
there to form the symbiosis with these
germinating seeds and powder products
can be very popular or in some cases
when like alfalfa they mix the seeds
with granular products because the size
of the seed is the same as the granular
size so they can just spread or sprinkle
together and I think that's what I had
for today that's where we see the most
benefits yes when the conditions are
optimal let's say an optimum irrigation
or fertilization
you know the plants won't really need
too much help to absorb more nutrients
or water so we see most most benefits
yes yes there are different formulations
yet that contains four five
nine species guess have you any
questions
Geneva campus do you have any questions
so if you're dealing with a an apple
tree coming bare root from a nursery man
isn't quite good to just have the
nursery man inoculate the roots or it's
much better to wait until they are just
going into the ground as as early as
possible so if they can apply it at the
nursery that's gonna be a much better
solution because by the time it is
transplanted into the field they can
provide the benefits and the symbiosis
has been already formed by the time
quick question about brassicas I've also
heard that there's you know scarcity of
symbiotic relationships has are you
aware of any studies where they've
tested older germ plasm or
even sort of the wild progenitors for
symbiotic relationships in what plant
species
Brassica a Brassica no no I am not aware
thank you although I call reading a
paper about a Brassica that that they
found a very mild colonization at their
later stage of their life just before
senescence which was very interesting
but I don't really remember any any germ
plasm tests or thank you Michael Ryan's
a first identified and when was their
first well I think it was the late 1800s
when they named mycorrhizae and in the
I would say in the 30s or 40s 1900s
1930s or 40s when they started to
recognize because earlier they thought
that they actually have a negative
effect on on the plans and they didn't
really look at look at a growth response
and what happened is well they certainly
didn't look at nutrient uptake and
nutrient content of the of the leaves
but in the 40s when they started to
recognize the benefits I'm curious about
the shelf life of these organisms and
packaged potting mix because some of the
artificial makes formulators or
incorporating various kinds of micro
easy and how long those mycorrhizae stay
active you know you know prepared
fighting that's before it gets well dry
and granular formulations have a three
and a five this is required from state
regulators however when it's mixed in
with with the soil
everything depends on the moisture
content of the soil so if it's a low
moisture content it's gonna have a
longer shelf life let's say one year or
up to two years however it has a if it
has a high moisture content over 40%
that could reduce the shelf life
significantly to even six months or one
year it depends on the components yes
the storage conditions for you what am i
quart of my Crosley inoculant industry
what I think is is
probably the high number of companies
that are popping up right now because
it's really easy so I didn't talk about
the production of mycorrhizae so there
is in vitro and in vivo production in
vitro is in that happens in the lab in
vivo is out the field and in vivo
production is really relatively easy to
do and smaller companies and to start
because it's start to grow mycorrhizae
on their own and without any any quality
control any field trial testing they
they market their product and they they
put everything on the label that has
been published for different species of
my crazy so what happens is that reduced
it reduces the credibility of of the
larger producers and because you know
it's just really hard to control and I
and I see that's the most important
problem to to to stay credible and and
just put you know those claims on the
label that you have been tested because
also the companies don't really have a
budget to execute a large-scale field
trial program to to test it in corn to
test it in in various species and that
creates some kind of attention because
you know there are hundreds of products
out there but growers just don't know
which one to choose because the
information is just not out there so I I
see that that's a that's a main issue
right now my crazy attitude grubbing
mixes or the garden center bags
mycorrhizae how you know that it'll work
for what you want to be growing or is it
wasted on maybe these species don't work
for tomato
trees yes actually that's that's another
main
that I have convention because you know
some companies just put a lot of things
in in potting mixes for example both
ecto mycorrhizae and endo mycorrhizae
and certainly you know the potting mix
that is labeled for vegetable use you
know there's ecto mycorrhizae in it you
just pay for extra my crazy it's never
gonna do anything or any harm any good
and that's that's a problem I see that
that there are several products out
there that that are marketed for
specific uses but not the right
components are there another right
species for example there are products
out there for ericaceous particularly
aggregations plants blueberries and
there's just ecto micro I see in it and
it just won't help so that's that's it's
kind of a problem didn't answer your
question I'm sorry oh how do you find
well I think it's it's best to call the
manufacturer and and get the information
directly from them because you know if
there's a credible company so they
should have a technical support
[Music]
department where they can provide you
know all this information or you can
certainly look it up online on the
internet and find papers but the easiest
is just to talk to them directly and and
get the information firsthand from them
so but I do want to again remind France
which students if you'd like to continue
the dialogue with dr. Ochs both will be
in room 22 plant science starting in 10
minutes or less thank you so much
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu